this is really exciting to see the power
that this show still has
over us 10 years after it started
is absolutely incredible now i have to
say a lot of shows
that uh get the kind of a claim that
breaking bad had
when they come to the finale they take a
lot of hits i thought it was incredible
breaking bad universally acclaimed for
the finale
isn't this right vince by everybody
except yes except
your mom yeah yeah my mom yeah is that
promising
that's true gail gilligan who's watching
this she's going to be giving me all
kinds of rafter crap about it mom made
it through
uh mr fantastic mooning me i think she's
she tuned out a long time ago so speak
freely about your mom okay all right
that's good to know
now she uh i'm not sure she would ever
watch breaking bad in the first place if
i hadn't been involved
because she's you know she's just a
sweet nice lady who is
you know doesn't want to see the bad guy
prevail in a tv show
at the end of breaking bad she said i
really wanted walt to get away with it
i just i wanted i wanted walter white to
get away
really scot-free got free yeah yeah yeah
so so she's
yeah i know what if you knew my mom you
would say that yeah
yeah what is the normal kind of show
that she watches on television she
watched a lot of hallmark channel stuff
and uh yeah
i know that that's what she watches and
then her son makes breaking news oh yeah
yeah
maybe maybe walter y did get away with
it maybe he did
i don't think so there was no it's
actually it's right if that had been
uh any other that had been a you know
horror any other horror movie
do you know what i mean a jason movie
just him lying there that's meaningless
was there a coroner's report
there was no coroner's report there was
right now
no fascinating was there a listing in
the obituaries no
yeah it sounds like cranston needs work
i know that's what i was going to say
yeah someone's trying way too hard no no
he went to sleep and then woke up
and it was a dream
let's talk about this it's global
phenomenon breaking bad a global
phenomenon across the world when you see
fans worldwide wearing a breaking bad
t-shirt or any kind of memorabilia you
don't shrink from approaching them do
you
no i'm attracted to them in a very quiet
way yeah
i like to walk up to them saddle up next
to them
and just say i like your t-shirt
they kind of recoil and go what who's
this
and they look at me and then i go
and i walk away as quickly as possible
wow i
i have this fantasy in my mind that they
go to their friends and go you're never
going to believe what i just saw there
was brian cranston there was
and they're going yeah yeah
now speaking of which i think was 2013
you came here
to san diego comic-con and you walked
the floor
but you wore a very realistic
walter white prosthetic is that right a
mask and the same clothes we have a
picture of you here
that's you that's me
you were they i have a slight elephant
yeah an elephant titus
i don't think going on yeah slightly
swollen head yeah but other than that
now what was that like
how did people react to you well we've
been coming to comic-con for a while and
and we've never been able to really
walk the floor and enjoy the atmosphere
of it
and so then i thought well this guy made
this wonderful mask and i thought
wait a minute if i wear the mask then i
can walk the floor so i just got the
mask
i got real walter white wardrobe yup and
i walked through now people were saying
hey is that really you and i'd go no
it's not
just i just love the show somewhere
between mickey mouse and and you know
michael jackson's
odd combination there now dean uh you
came here i think in 2012
and you appeared as xena for reasons
nobody understands
we think we have a pic
wow what i love about that photo is that
you are sexually harassing yourself
[Laughter]
yeah what was that all about where'd you
get the outfit god knows i
you know it was just in the garage and i
figured
you hadn't put it on in hours in hours
and uh yeah i'll be that guy yeah
you can just decide i'll go for it i'll
just be xena why not i did yeah and
everybody was freaking out about it
and i was like what the hell is he doing
yeah what happened
what happened to dean i was not
surprised you were not that's not a
surprise at all yeah it's not a surprise
at all you looked hot
yeah yeah i disagree
uh aaron you uh you still
now you have a daughter and now what's
it like if you're with your daughter
first of all i'm hoping the yo [ __ ] is
like maybe tapering off a little bit not
really no
no no no i get i get called a [ __ ]
every day
yeah i mean it used to be so many times
a day
now it's like three to five times now
what's that like it's from his wife
[Laughter]
i love you babe wherever you are um you
you have a
is it a little girl is that yeah a
little little five-month-old
five-month-old girl i mean how do you
feel she's too young now
she's here she's here yeah uh her name
is
she's the best yeah what how do you feel
about the fact that
uh you might be walking around with your
child two three years from now
and people are gonna go yo [ __ ] at you
call you a [ __ ] in front of your
daughter how are you preparing for this
i mean i'm just afraid that it may be
her first word
yeah i i really she's gonna hear it so
much
she'll be used to it yeah yeah i just
have to sit her down and explain it to
her yeah
yeah show her show the show you know
it was so amazing during the commercial
break uh you got a lot of you got up and
started mingling and talking to each
other because you hadn't seen each other
in a while
well not you you were a little
standoffish but uh but for the most part
for the most part you were mingling and
talking and then we started chatting and
i was saying
wait a minute it wasn't then the show
just stopped like two years you said
it's been five years
that blows my mind that it's happening
that it's been that soon wow it scares
me
yeah it's frightening yeah we're all
rocking through the grave all right i'm
still
showing up for work conan and i still
show up for work all the time
i don't know you're there show up for
work
who shows up so there's two of you with
a good work ethic that really cares
yeah keep showing up all you got to do
yeah
all you got to do is fly to albuquerque
and they'll put your heart
on possibly killed one of them
okay you just brought up you just
brought up deaths uh rj there were 270
deaths
on the show 270 deaths on the show you
had an idea for another
that you pitched and it didn't go is
that right yeah i kind of pitched
i i they're talking about killing
someone i said
well junior would be a good one to kill
and like you said kill junior i mean
yeah
it's like there's a game about that
right who would kill junior
oh i was hoping someone good someone had
to be good
the cousins the cousins louis and danny
montana i was like i was assuming
because i read it and i was like oh my
my part i don't have a lot in any of
this script and
all the season i'm like oh man i'm like
losing i'm losing lines and then these
guys show up and i'm like
wait i'm next yeah you thought you were
you thought you were a goner no one's
safe no one was safe on this show so
okay this this brings a good good
question because vince
did you ever did you ever even think
about
getting rid of our discord did you ever
think about it i did actually i
uh you did yeah that's insane oh i know
by the way and who was gonna who was
gonna kill him you know and that part we
hadn't figured out but uh
and by the way you realize you once once
you get killed you don't get paid
anymore right so that
that i didn't know you were hoping for
giving your contract
yeah but that was the giancarlo yeah
i think it's not true i i i early on i
pitched to
my writers i had this idea where walter
jr there's this horrible uh
you know he gets killed by this nasty
guy that walt is somehow
in business with and i had this whole
thing
late it would take too long to even
pitch it here and all my writers looked
at me
like i was had completely lost my mind
it was the most horrible person ever
like no people would have
i don't think people would have accepted
junior being murdered
i and you know and you know they're all
saying enough people tell you you're
drunk you need to sit down my writers
essentially told me i was drunk yeah and
uh you've really been drinking now yeah
it's
uh anna you're let's talk about your uh
audition your audition for the show was
was quite i think bizarre is the right
word
yeah would you like to talk about that
well i guess so
um it was it was very interesting i um
i had about what 15 minutes to rehearse
with brian
and and vince and uh before the test
and we were doing the scenes chosen for
me one of them was the um
the handsome yeah hand pleasuring
hand pleasuring sleep seeing the scene
of you mean like a massage a massage a
massage
i like that you just shouted out hand
job like what's that why are people
you're like hand job what's your problem
i know he's a kid he's a kid
yeah got no values yeah it was just a
gentle massage and
um so we rehearsed and i said i don't
want to you know i thought it would be
goofy to do
an error mime of to create the uh the
virtual space of that
correct so we sat down and figured out
uh
a little i told her if you're really
courageous you should just go for
he said you know if you if you really
want this part then
oh hang up
[Laughter]
he said he said don't touch me actually
don't touch me um
but we put two chairs together and there
was a little you know arm
arm on the chair that that i massaged
yes um so you did that and that was uh
you thought the correct
yeah i thought that was the correct
thing and it worked out and it was it
was a laugh fest
and so my my audition was sort of like a
comedy audition
and then and then who knew that it would
not there wasn't necessarily a laugh
riot going on
no this is interesting because you
brought up the idea that it was a comedy
audition
betsy you were on the impression when
you auditioned for the show that it was
an all-out comedy oh i thought it was
funny funny funny funny
um i mean i didn't think it was like
half hour laugh track
but i thought this was just a very dark
cable comedy which i said for a while
and then i think maybe it was finally
season three i caught on
and i i said to the vince i said no it's
just a very very
very very dark comedy and then it just
the lights went out it was dark
[Laughter]
because there's lung cancer in the
opening episode you know
that wasn't a clue at all i don't know
yeah you know funny shows i had worse
things right
yeah sure all right yeah hogan's heroes
yes kids look it up on youtube uh
they don't understand uh giancarlo uh is
such
a an amazing performance oh thanks such
an incredible performance
really spectacular the
few actors can be so unnerving uh just
staring uh at someone uh you're doing it
now to me
are you okay not not okay i'm not okay
can i refresh your water for you
you're such a powerful uh commitment to
your character
is it true that you actually rattled uh
but you tried to get to
brian in scenes where you two were
facing off you tried to get to him as an
actor and try and rattle him is that
true well uh i think it is true
yes i love working with brian and brian
always gives you all of his attention
so i thought i would be able to get
all of mine uh yes you know there were
certain moments especially in an episode
401 box cutter where you know there are
no words whatsoever being said yes
and i come in and do my action and i
have to glance over at
uh both brian and aaron and i
circled aaron at one point and he kind
of flinched and i realized oh
wow he may be a little bit afraid of me
yeah in character
in character a little afraid of you and
that's a power that you have another
uh secret power you have you're a
terrific singer you're you're an amazing
you yourself are a very good singer
did you ever think of incorporating that
into your character
uh gus well i did think to pitch to
vince
gus's last moment would be very very
different
he would actually get up and he would
say i love life
i want to live i
love life
yes
wow i figured that might keep my paint
set
yes oh the show that could have been
i don't know i bet it would have sounded
different with half your face missed
bob uh you know what's interesting uh
this the
the idea of your character saul getting
a spin-off series
was suggested on your first day of
shooting is that right
as i recall it the scene with brian in
in the lawyer's office
uh where saul is introducing himself
somebody shouted out behind the camera
can i get a job on the sequel yeah and
everyone laughed
at the notion and so i don't know if
that started things but vince very
quickly
started talking about there's more to
the character maybe
than we're seeing in this show yeah it
was interesting this has been
uh an amazing transformation for you
because
uh for years uh iconic comedy performer
and working you know solely in the
sketch world now you're getting
nominated every year
conan actually it's interesting a long
time ago when i was starting out i was
part of uh
i did some acting i i was part of a duo
an acting duo an acting duo well yeah
it's
it hasn't caught on
it's an acting team an actor and it's
the two people
and one provides the uh facial
expressions yes
and the other okay now i know what we're
doing all right audio
sound i have a head shot from my team uh
this is from
quite a long time starting out yeah
there we go there's me
and uh
that is it's uh that was one of the
dumbest things we came on we
performed that at the victory gardens
theater in chicago in 1988 and we would
go on stage together
as thespians that's so specialized that
i would do
all the physical facial stuff and you
would make noises
it was the dumbest well it was so
dumb but it cracked us up and you would
get underneath me
with a microphone and i would just make
stupid cartoony faces and you were like
it was oh dumb but people it was really
fun to do it was
uh hot it was a hot ticket
we kept our clothes on yeah and it
worked
it was fun to do sadly sadly you kept
your clothes on yeah uh
i have to ask one last question uh vince
uh
so many people describe it as if not the
perfect show the near perfect show
any regrets is there anything that you
do differently if you go back in time
and do anything differently on the show
honestly there is and it has to do with
this gentleman right here yeah
show them the show show them your teeth
isn't that the
prettiest set of choppers you've ever
seen
and and this guy you got your ass kicked
so much
yeah like every like ever you know like
uh three times an episode for 62
episodes
plus you're smoking a lot of meth that's
bad and he's a man he's a meth addict
can't you go back digitally and i would
pay for it
and screw up his teeth in every episode
i would i think we
don't you want to see that i will make
sure that you look like [ __ ] in every
episode
i'll do that for you for the show turn
the money i got it
okay